Frosty the Snowman technically a snow
golem oh yeah yeah yes yeah yes no this
is not technically just this
John's taking us on the backcountry
through the same his fourth time skiing
real Sam survives what will you survive
in the mountain does anyone have a
camera is there a headed Kevin trying to
get at least 50 miles an hour today
because you know honestly like I heard
faster you go the easier gets ya where
have you put most your attributes today
you know into like the grind balance air
time handling
yeah y'all see the tree throwing it fell
in front of me right look at this fresh
[ __ ] I love it so forth I'm skiing
these guys think all right yeah let's
check this place up is like the hardest
place in the park and I'm like cool I'm
down for whatever
basically I ate it real hard every
single time it was overcast I think I
had something to do with it yeah I had
the wrong colored lenses and stuff so
Sam Sam can we just get one final quote
from you uh yeah um what a ride
exam dies what's the verdict on Sam at
his current status did Roughrider
who told anybody yet so we figure we can
get a little more skiing and then we can
tell people cuz yeah
favorite old funeral either way I mean
he already is toast
so why I like her the rest of our day
you know it's like totally it sucks but
it is what it is let's finish out our
day strong and then deal with the
consequence what he would've wanted yes
yes
what right
working basically oh no my god why why
why this video has to be done by the end
of the day in a thirty five thirty yeah
how's it going